Kris Jenner seemingly drops a major hint  about Kylie and Khloe's rumored  pregnancies when you grow up but or when  you have a baby  I taught my kids from day one you know  families everything on a holiday special  of keeping up with the kardashians the  reality TV family takes turns sharing  what they are thankful for at the dinner  table I don't know if I'm thankful for  the calm before the storm next year with  a new babies and I'm thankful that we  have family  Kim is expecting her third child via  surrogate next year but a teary eyed  Kris seems to spill a little more when  she opens up about her expanding family  and now it's like a faucet that we  turned on it's been  using journey to watch your kids because  it's truly the leaving of just left  [Music]  you